let's start with cameron in
los angeles hi cameron welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me on i really
appreciate it you too
how can we help well i'm new to your
plan
um i just found it uh maybe a month ago
and um you know i'm in serious amount of
debt
uh right now i have a total of 745
000 worth of debt and uh you know i'm
really
really anxious to get out of it you know
made some mistakes
and um i didn't even realize but you
know i was making them but
after hearing your show you know i
really think that you know i want to
get my life you know straightened out
and uh you know
i want to aim for financial freedom
okay um what kind of debt do you have
so um i have it all broken down well i
have a home
and it's 525 000. i feel better already
for real i just exhaled
i was afraid you had 745 000 student
loan debt or something i didn't know
what to tell you okay
yeah 525 000 on the home what's that
home worth by the way
so right now it's about seven we're
worth about 700. okay cool
all right and what's the other 220
thousand i have
uh 150 and student loan
i have uh you're gonna get upset but i
have 29 timeshare
and um 30 personal loan
10 in car and 10 in credit card
okay all right and who's the person
loaned to a bank
uh yeah okay all right and are you a
doctor or a lawyer
uh neither nurse practitioner no oh no
that's good okay
all right i thought i thought with that
student loan bill there may be something
involved here
so what are you making so right now
i make a 135
000 good news and you're what 28.
um 30 30. okay close i expect
um my um
my time's gonna go up so about 150 to
180 in the next year
excellent excellent okay good well
you're not afraid of work that's good
news
are you married yeah okay
cool so uh what is it you want to
accomplish here
i um i just you know i made a lot i made
a lot of mistakes
and i kind of just want you know the
best way to get on track you know
um i'm the first in my family to you
know
to ever graduate college and even have
you know
some level of success with money and you
know i want to make sure
i change you know my family's tree so
well congratulations
that's awesome i hold a bad note and i
want to just fix it
it's a wonderful start good for you it's
awesome man oh
well the the the bad news is there's a
mess
uh the good news is that the hole that
you're in uh compared to the shovel that
you have 130 to 180 income
is uh this is very doable okay
uh so it just depends on how quickly you
want to do this and how deeply you want
to sacrifice
obviously the more deeply you sacrifice
the quicker you'll get out does that
make sense
yes because we'll use more of your
income to clean up the mess
the more deeply you sacrifice and or you
sell that house and you've gotten rid of
most of it
so not suggesting you do that but i'm
just saying those are sacrifices
no life no house but the death's all
gone and you start fresh
and you could do that pretty quick i i
don't think i would in your case i think
i would if i were in your shoes i'd hold
on to the house
and let's uh plow through 220 000
worth of debt making a hundred and fifty
to two hundred
um let's just play with some numbers if
you put fifty thousand on it
uh or seventy five thousand on it it
takes you three years
which is two thousand bucks a month no
it's not
i wish it was 2 000 bucks a month it's
not even close yeah it's way more than
6 000 bucks a month thank you but um
anyway yeah if you do that that's 75 000
a year you'll be debt free in three
years translation
you have absolutely no life you're
working so many overtime shifts your
eyes are crossing
you are living on beans and rice rice
and beans you are not going on vacation
and you're not going to see the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working
there's your extra job which you
shouldn't do as a nurse practitioner you
ought to be nursing as your second job
okay i can do that i can do that i kind
of think you can i know you can
i think you're the guy because did you
follow the math with me 75 times three
is two and a quarter
yeah but seventy five thousand bucks
six thousand bucks a month out of your
income means you're working extra and
you are living
on nothing
and you're going to list these debts
smallest to largest and you're going to
attack them
with a vengeance and your community
who has seen you as the guy that got out
the first guy to go to college the first
guy to get the big fancy job the guy
that works in the hospital
is not gonna understand why you're
driving a crummy car and working on the
weekends
they're not gonna understand why you're
not picking up the tab
and that's why they're broke and this is
the
this is the gut wrenching moment when
you change the family tree with the hard
hard stuff now
honestly cameron the the people that
have done this stuff that we've worked
with over 30 years the ones that are the
most successful
care the least about what other people
think
caring what other people think it will
kill you
on this so if broke people are making
fun of your financial plan you're always
on track
okay i really appreciate it so really
quick you you don't think i should
get rid of the house not unless you have
to
if you if you can if you can lean into
it for three years
if you if you want to move anyway okay
that's fine but if you want to hold on
to a piece of california real estate
which is not a bad idea
and you want to lean into this and bust
it
then i think you can keep the house and
still be done in three years or sooner
um if i thought it was going to take you
10 years i'd sell the house
okay but the math says it's not if
cameron says
he can do it and it's all up to cameron
now but we'll help you
we have a thing called ramsay plus and
we're going to give you a one-year
subscription to that
and that puts you into the financial
peace university class it puts you into
the every dollar premium version of the
budgeting app
it puts you into the baby steps tracker
it connects you up with all the tools
like the debt snowball tool it connects
you with
everything you need to be able to move
to the next level
and to cause all this to happen
including community and coaches
and everything else i'm going to give it
to you because i just want to start
this hour that way and you are on i
think he's going
he's going man he's going to do it i
know he's doing it call me back give me
that free scream man
i'm smiling brother i love it three
years from now i'll be sitting here
waiting on you
hold on kelly i'll pick up we'll get you
signed up